bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à bruxelles pour
une nouvelle émission d'europe indoor et
dans cette émission reportage une école
pour pister l'argent sale une trentaine
de policiers de magistrats européens de
haut niveau se forment à strasbourg
mission lutter contre le blanchiment
d'argent la corruption l'évasion fiscale
cette formation est une première en
europe financé à 90% par la commission
européenne simulation de perquisitions
cas pratiques former ensemble des
enquêteurs de plusieurs pays est ce un
atout pour les coopérations à venir
c'est ce que nous allons voir dans le
reportage de charles vi n'a nommé avant
à d'autres sujets les municipales en
france vous le savez elles sont passées
une déroute pour la gauche françois
hollande on a tiré les conséquences en
nommant un nouveau premier ministre mais
déjà les élections européennes se
profile celle valls avait un troisième
tour
françois hollande et sa majorité ont
largement perdu la bataille des
élections municipales mais une autre
arrive trouver 50 milliards d'euros sur
la période 2015 2017 le chef de l'état
rendez vous avec l'europe la lutte
contre les déficits il a promis des
économies de 50 milliards en trois ans
mais où trouver ces 50 milliards d'euros
d'économies avant 2017 le gouvernement
qui ne parvient pas à baisser le chômage
devra rendre des comptes à bruxelles en
avril sur sa trajectoire budgétaire
dépenses recettes déficit endettement il
a aussi rendez vous en france avec le
vote au parlement du pack de
responsabilité baisse des charges
patronales contre promesse d'embauché
d'ici là françois hollande or at il
tranché sur les sacrifices que l'état
les collectivités locales les
fonctionnaires les chômeurs les
intermittents les bénéficiaires de
prestations sociales doivent faire pour
prouver ces 50 milliards d'économies
cela ne concerne tous de près ou de loin
retour du déficit à 3% hollande demande
à demi mots un délai à l'europe le
gouvernement aura aussi à convaincre
l'europe que cette contribution de la
france à la compétitivité à la
croissance doit être prise en compte
dans le respect de nos engagements
la commission européenne elle-même ne se
fait guère plus d'espoir elle a déjà
prévu un déficit important en france et
demande à paris des mesures
supplémentaires pour le stabiliser ce
déficit au risque de fragiliser la
croissance tant désirée par le chef de
l'état les élections européennes c'est
le 25 mai elle risque de se transformer
en 3e tour des municipales
alors nous avons été rejoints sur ce
plateau par jean marie cavada bonjour
aux députés udf numéro deux de la liste
présentée par l'alternative en
ile-de-france s'est conduite par
marielle de sarnez alors question toute
simple jean marie cavada est ce que
c'est pas ce dimanche 30 mars au soir du
second tour des municipales que le décor
il a été planté pour les élections
européennes non il n'ya pas un grand
rapport d'abord je vais faire une
observation parce que parlant aux
électeurs et donc aux citoyens
j'aimerais quand même qu'on dise la
vérité et non pas des fantasmes quelle
est la vérité c'est que le front
national en total de voix à fait le même
score qu'il avait fait la dernière fois
c'est à dire quelque chose comme 7,7 et
demi pour cent donc aussi spectaculaire
que l'on puisse considérer la prise d'un
certain nombre de villes il y en a quand
même pas 3000 1 il y en a une dizaine
douzaine et c'est bien normal après tout
puisqu'il puisqu'il ya des électeurs il
ne faudrait pas faire il ne faudrait pas
commencer à avoir ycompris dans certains
médias les yeux de chimène pour les
bleus pour le front national et son
futur scrutin supposée voilà la réalité
ça c'est une première chose deuxièmement
le scrutin européen c'est un scrutin qui
va un peu parlé d'europe mais aussi
hélas pour nous pays en très mauvais
état depuis une trentaine d'années faut
quand même le dire le déficit qui datent
pas d'aujourd'hui
les élections européennes se rendent des
élections largement de défoulement nous
devons donc mobiliser toutes les forces
républicaines ceux qui sont au
gouvernement sedan l'opposition qui
savent et pensent et oseront dire à
leurs électeurs la france n'a pas
d'avenir hors de l'europe que maintenant
et en gros il faut cesser de regarder
les sondages le matin et la caméra du 20
heures le soir il faut dire la vérité le
pays est dans une situation extrêmement
grave et quand ça va mal qui payent pas
ceux qui parlent au dessus c'est le
peuple là bas mais je le dis ça parce
que ceux qui regardent madame le pen ils
vont payer la facture de madame le pen
si un jour elle s'approchait de pouvoir
mais sur ces 50 milliards d'économies
qu'il faut trouver
d'ici à 2017 ou qu'est-ce qu'on coupe où
on va les trouver il ya plusieurs axes
ne pour pour cette dépense il faut il
faut restreindre la dépense publique je
vais vous donner un seul exemple en 1980
il y avait environ 2 millions 400 500
mille fonctionnaires des trois fonctions
publiques
françaises la fonction des
fonctionnaires du statut national la
fonction territoriale et la santé trente
ans plus tard nous sommes 5 millions 4,5
millions 6 quelqu'un qui viendrait de la
planète mars va se dire mais ce pays a
doublé d'habitants on était cinquante
cinq millions est-ce qu'on est 110
millions non on est simplement 65
millions pour dégraisser la bouscule nos
services mais oui mais absolument
pourquoi tant de doubler le nombre
d'administrateurs de la france alors
qu'on n'a pas doublé de population c'est
un laisser-aller épouvantable et il va
bien falloir redresser ça parce que
sinon c'est maintenant que tout les
jeunes générations qui entre de l'emploi
et d'ailleurs qui n'arrive pas à y
entrer bon payer une terrible facture
avec des conséquences sociales et des
conséquences politiques que les
marchands de peur attendent au coin du
bois pour essayer de faire leur propre
fortune si vous voyez ce que je veux
dire en 2013 le déficit on est à 4,3
pour cent de la richesse nationale
bruxelles rappelle à françois hollande
ses engagements bruxelles va pas lâcher
la faire écouter je suis pas dans la
peau du commissaire aux questions à mon
avis ça va se terminer et il faut que ça
se termine par une négociation mais je
pense que il faudrait que la commission
demande à monsieur hollande des
engagements précis de redressement du
déficit de la réorganisation du marché
du travail c'est-à-dire au fond faire
les réformes que monsieur schneider qui
est à des derniers grands hommes dette
en europe et monsieur art son compagnon
de réformes ancien patron de volkswagen
ancien drh de volkswagen dont un type
qui ne parle pas de n'importe quoi qui a
été reçu d'ailleurs que mon chien sur un
jeu de quilles en france qui n'est pas à
la gloire de nos de nos institutions par
parenthèse eh bien il faut maintenant
que nous négocions et que la commission
demande à monsieur hollande un
engagement précis sur les réformes en
cours est sûre je dirais le calendrier
ou les réformes doit produire leurs
effets jean marie cavada vous parlez de
marine le pen écoutez ses voeux pour ces
élections européennes
c'est le 25 mai écoutez fait voeux et
vous réagissez juste après
je le répète le front national peut
arriver en tête aux élections entre 20
et 25% jeu mon objectif c'est d'arriver
en tête c'est de créer une prise de
conscience de ce que l'union européenne
est en train de faire vivre un autre
pays de l'immense souffrance qui est la
conséquence de la soumission de nos
gouvernements à des règles à des diktats
qui sont aujourd'hui inouïe dans leurs
conséquences en terme de baisse des
salaires des fondements du pouvoir
d'achat de concurrence internationale
déloyale 2 d'augmentation massive du
chômage
thomas jean marie cavada est ce que
c'est possible donc une majorité
d'eurosceptiques au parlement
elles ne représentent pas les
eurosceptiques elles représentent les
antieuropéens des gens de bonne foi
d'ailleurs pourrait se demander pour
quelle étonnante raisons esthétiques
étant totalement contre l'europe elle
vient se faire salariés en europe en ce
qui me concerne si je suis contre la
ligue des pêcheurs je vais pas leur
payer une cotisation et encore moins
leur demander un salaire ceci doit être
entendu par les électeurs il faut de la
rectitude surtout quand les choses sont
difficiles il ya une deuxième chose
cette dame elle a eu un cabinet
d'avocats elle connaît le monde elle
avait probablement des clients des
clients qui n'étaient pas français elle
sait très bien que l'ouverture de la
france sur le monde et notamment sur
l'europe est une nécessité plus de 60%
du commerce extérieur que nous
produisons des produits manufacturés ou
des services notre marché c'est leur
option sort de l'union nos produits
seront renchérit par des droits de
douane en allemagne en italie en espagne
etc vous voyez un peu les centaines de
milliers de chômeurs que ça va produire
est-ce qu'elle va chiffrer ça est ce
qu'elle va dire le nombre d'emplois
supplémentaires que le fait de sortir de
l'europe va naturellement non non parce
qu'elle sait bien qu on en perdrait
immensément autrement dit je voit se
dessiner dans une sorte d'imprécisions
et d'invectivés une sorte de parti de la
peur ou deux parties du dégoût c'est pas
avec ça qu'on va redresser dans le pays
ce dans les familles qui seraient tentés
de voter aux sceptiques ou
anti-européens qu'est ce que vous leur
dit non ne mélangeons pas monsieur
eurosceptiques héros citoyens
anti-européen eurosceptique et
pro-européen ya que trois courants en
france madame le pen c'est les anti
européens et de là dedans mais tout on
met tous et même s'il fait pas beau
j'attends le moment où elle va dire que
c'est la faute de l'europe non c'est pas
acceptable
les eurosceptiques ce sont des gens très
intéressants parce qu'il faut leur dire
que ce qui va mal en france le chômage
c'est pas l'europe et madame le pen est
trop intelligente pour beat ne poserait
pas connaître ça et si elle venait ici
plus souvent elles verraient que c'est
pas du tout ça non le chômage c'est
parce que la france n'a pas fait ses
réformes c'est pas les contraintes de
bruxelles sinon l'allemagne triage où
elle a les mêmes règles que nous il ne
faut pas tromper les gens c'est beaucoup
trop grave et je pense que nous devons
nous lever dans un mouvement de vérité
je dis pas que l'europe est parfaite je
dis que sans l'europe deux sont morts et
j'ai pas envie de mourir j'ai pas envie
que mes enfants meurent j'ai pas envie
que le pays ne devienne l'italie en
attendant de devenir l'egypte j'ai pas
envie il ya un dernier sondage ans qui
viennent qui vient de tomber qui donne
22% des français voteraient pour l'ump
aux élections européennes pour le ppe
20% pour le pour le front national et
18% pour le parti socialiste ça vous
inspire quoi ça m'inspire que c'est un
sondage et je veux pas passer mon temps
à commenter ce qui va venir on verra
bien comment ça s'est un peu trop tôt
personne n'a fait campagne donc mais
c'est un fait que l'europe a besoin
d'être réservé aux campagnes sur quoi je
vais faire campagne nous allons madame
de sarnez
chantal jouanno numéro 3 et moi c'est à
dire l'ensemble udi et modem de l'enfer
campagne sur une chose simple si vous
pensez que l'europe c'est l'avenir des
réformes en france c'est la façon de
tirer la france vers l'eau et donc de de
pourvoir les emplois alors votez pour
les européens entre madame le pen et
nous en réalité il ya personne parce que
même quand il ya des européens ailleurs
ils n'osent pas le dire tantôt parce que
le parti dans lequel auquel ils
appartiennent le redis
moderato cantabile n'en parlez pas trop
quoi tantôt parce qu'ils n'ont aucune
conception européenne et puis par dessus
tout nous sommes des français nous avons
signé des traités dont nous avons tiré
prospérité et grandeur et même s'il ya
du chômage la france serait petit s'il
n'y avait pas eu l'europe il faut
regarder les choses en face sur ce sujet
qu'est ce que vous allez aspire ce
constat fait il ya quelques jours par un
de vos anciens collègues jean louis
bourlanges ancien député européen de
centre-droit qui disait ça fait 50 ans
qu'on fait l'europe mais ça fait 50 ans
qu'on fait l'europe avec des gens qui ne
veulent pas de l'europe oui c'est pas
tout à fait faux ça les gens qui ont
dirigé l'europe depuis plusieurs
décennies n'étaient pas des européens
convaincus qu'en les
chrétiens-démocrates et les chrétiens
sociaux ont quitté les gouvernements
européens
la notion d'europe c'était beaucoup plus
effondrée et le dernier qui était au
pouvoir en europe c'était jacques delors
est ce que vous diriez à jacques delors
qui n'a pas fait du bien à l'europe et à
la france moi en tout cas je le dirai
pas merci jean marie cavada merci à vous
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et
maintenant place aux reportages lutte
contre le blanchiment d'argent la
corruption ou l'évasion fiscale
strasbourg strasbourg on forme des
fonctionnaires de tous les états membres
de l'union européenne contre ces fléaux
et ça marche
regardez le reportage de charleville à 9
ok
de loin cela ressemble à une sortie
touristique aux attaques des soit de
près le lieutenant-colonel philip marris
mène son groupe à la baguette ortec
vaisseau en place ok go
ils sont juges magistrats ou encore
policiers venus de tous les pays de
l'union européenne ils sont 30 à avoir
fait le déplacement
objectif apprendre à traquer l'argent
sale pendant trois semaines il alterne
entre pratique et théorie au programme
du jour une simulation de perquisitions
sans arlette d'ascot de
heidi
vérification
hold up et aux fraudes via gaulle et non
pendant la scène le lieutenant-colonel
traduit et explique toutes les étapes du
contrôle
et se posent tous gaulle
les élèves ne sont pas novices ils ont
été triés sur le volet dans leurs pays
respectifs
avaloq rare de dow jones qu'est ce que
vous avez dans les poches monsieur
and because they found some drogue
it is enough for us to search
légitime est
justement lors de la fouille les
gendarmes trouvent des documents
attestant de flux financiers illégaux
c'est là que les enquêteurs entre en jeu
ils vont devoir remonter à la source du
trafic une mise en situation qu'ils
apprécient
tout cela a l'air vrai c'est très
différent dans mon pays ici ils font ça
calmement rapidement ils savent ce
qu'ils font ils sont professionnels
intérieur pour fonctionner avec ce genre
de formation et plus d'interactions
entre les pays on pourrait accélérer les
enquêtes et être plus efficace à
l'avenir
la coopération un des enjeux majeurs de
cet apprentissage entre les contacts et
les informations recueillies l'union
européenne y trouve son compte c'est
pourquoi elles financent la formation à
hauteur de 90% les 10% restants sont
prises en charge par la ville et
l'université de strasbourg
chantal cutajar est à l'initiative du
programme très vite elle a compris
l'importance d'une collaboration entre
les européens
7 l'occasion d'échanger des pratiques ce
qui va nous permettre nous également de
présenter à la commission européenne un
état des lieux des bonnes pratiques voir
ce qui fonctionne bien voir pourquoi ça
ne fonctionne pas at elle est à
l'endroit et qui nous permettra de faire
des préconisations en termes législatifs
ou en termes opérationnels
en matière de fraude fiscale larnack se
niche dans les détails du coup la
formation passe en revue tous les
aspects de l'investigation financière
des cours très spécialisés qui nécessite
parfois des experts chantal cutajar a
fait appel ard le taux que du service
des douanes il est venu pour expliquer
une escroquerie bien connue des
autorités françaises la fraude à la tva
est ce qu'on vient enseigner c'est un
petit peu la méthodologie détection et
surtout la méthodologie d'action le
partage d'informations la nécessaire
restructuration
des échanges avec les pays étrangers
puisque par défaut cette fraude était de
type international est concerné
plusieurs pays la formation est victime
de son succès elle n'organise que deux
sessions par an alors que la demande ne
cesse d'augmenter l'évasion fiscale est
désormais dans le viseur des états
membres et pour cause elle coûterait
plus de 1000 milliards d'euros à l'union
européenne soit plus de quatre fois le
budget de la france
voilà c'est un reportage de charles
villanove nous avons été rejoints sur ce
plateau par françoise castex bonjour
vous êtes eurodéputés nouvelle donne à
vous avez quitté récemment le groupe
socialiste pourquoi socialiste et je
suis encore dans le groupe cic démocrate
jusqu'à la fin la mandature calcul parti
socialiste passer à gauche qu'il n'y
avait jamais eu certains désaccords
effectivement sur l'orientation du parti
socialiste notamment sur les politiques
d'austérité sur le pacte de
responsabilité mais je sais pas si on
est là pour parler de ça aujourd'hui une
autre fois à vos côtés jean paul gauzès
bonjour vous êtes euro députés ppe vous
confirmez vous reste à l'ump vous et je
laisse à l'ump voilà alors question
toute simple vous avez vous envie de
regarder ce reportage une école pour
pister l'argent sale madame monsieur le
député ça vous inspire quoi
c'est un début de coopération
l'union européenne a pointé cette ce
problème de la corruption de l'évasion
fiscale il n'y a même créé au sein du
parlement européen une commission
spéciale sur la criminalité organisée
dans lequel je siégeais et ce type de
formation est à une petite échelle vin
chaud à l'ampleur du problème ce qu'il
faut faire ce qu'il faut initier en
formation mais aussi incompétents
pération institutionnel entre les
polices et en ce qui me concerne je
propose des mesures beaucoup plus forte
avec la création d'un paquet d'un
parquet européen de manière à ce qu'il
puisse y avoir une saisine d'un juge
européen puisque c'est de la criminalité
transnationale et que quelquefois il est
très difficile de les coincer au niveau
la justice dans un état membre et puis
des sanctions de type confiscation des
biens et puis une liste noire par
exemple des entreprises qui fraudent qui
ne pourraient plus
soumissionner à des marchés publics jean
paul gauzès on devrait être plus
ambitieux je voyais ce reportage à peine
à 2 deux idées simples la première c'est
que un certain nombre d'événements ne
peuvent être traitées qu'au niveau
européen et on voit là l'utilité de
l'union européenne la coopération
nécessaire entre les états pour éviter
qu'il y ait des endroits d'un endroit où
de protection conforte deuxième aspect
c'est tout sur lequel moi je souhaite
insister c'est la différence entre la
fraude fiscale est ce qu'on pourrait
appeler l'évitement fiscal la fraude
fiscale c'est un délit ce doit être
poursuivie réprimer avec les dispositifs
qui était voté l'évitement fiscal c'est
le fait qu'un contribuable et celle
également légalement de ne pas payer des
impôts plus tueur il a envie de faire et
cet évitement fiscale peut être lui même
évoqué tout peut être évité si on a une
meilleure harmonisation fiscale au
niveau européen à ce moment là il n'y
aura pas des niches ou des possibilité
d'échapper à l'impôt mais on ne doit pas
mélanger la fraude et l'évitement fiscal
ou ce qu'on appelle aussi l'optimisation
fiscale voilà alors madame la députée
monsieur le député la directrice de
l'école elle vous interpelle vous les
parlements talent vous pose une question
on écoute sa question et vous réagissez
juste après
seriez vous prêt à initier à soutenir
une résolution pour demander à la
commission européenne d'adopter un
instrument juridique européen pour
promouvoir les investigations
financières à l'échelle de l'union
européenne
voilà une résolution pour demander à la
commission de promouvoir les
investigations financières à l'échelle
européenne c'est ce que vous demande la
directrice de l'école c'est possible ou
pas mais sûr que c'est possible quand je
vous parlais tout à l'heure d'un parquet
européen
c'est à ça que je pensais il ya eu des
votes déjà du parlement européen qui
sont favorables à l'institution de ce
juge européen là où je rejoins jean paul
gauzès s'est vraiment plus d'europe
qu'il faut pour traiter ce sujet et ce
parquet pourrait avoir des sections
spécialisées dans la production sierre
dans la traite des êtres humains pour
traquer et pour juger et pour
sanctionner
toute la criminalité organisée au niveau
transnational
alors il ya la fraude et l'évasion
fiscale fraude évasion fiscale c'est 2
milliards d'euros qui plombent qui
plombent leur a bien quelques jours
l'autriche luxembourg à se sont mis
d'accord ils ont dit au revoir aux
secrets au secret bancaire après six
longues années de blocage les dpi ont
fait accepter d'y mettre fin c'était il
ya quelques jours ça va changer quoi
concrètement jean paul gauzès pour
répondre à une question de la directrice
je réponds oui oui sans réserve
deuxièmement le parlement a voté très
récemment une résolution sur la question
de la fraude fiscale et nous avons une
très large majorité j'étais des
cosignataires avec mes collègues de
gauche de ce texte sur et donc sur la
fin du secret bancaire effectivement le
texte était bloqué pour la petite
histoire le dossier sur la fiscalité
d'epargne a été terminé du côté du
parlement à la fin du mandat précédent
le rapporteur était quelqu'un qui a fait
son chemin depuis c'est benoît hamon et
puis pendant cinq ans les choses ont
traîné les choses ont traîné et
maintenant finalement l'autriche et la
suivit la suisse l'autriche et le
luxembourg ont accepté l'échangé
automatique d'informations ça va changer
c'est que ça ne sera pas aux
administrations d'aller pêcher des
informations là où elles ont des
soupçons elles recevront directement les
informations utiles concernant les
mouvements financiers et c'est une bonne
chose parlons maintenant de la
corruption la corruption pense aux pays
du tiers-monde finalement ça concerne
aussi l'europe
il ya ce sondage
cette étude eurobaromètre sur la
perception des européens
plus des trois quarts des européens
estiment que les pots de vin les emplois
fictifs les détournements publics et
autres financement occulte de partis
politiques je cite sont très répandus
très répandue en europe c'est leur
perception il ya les faits aussi pour la
première fois la commission européenne
ya quelques jours a présenté un rapport
sur la corruption qui représenterait 120
milliards d'euros chaque année dans les
28 est-ce qu'on manque de volonté
politique pour pour combattre ce fléau
françois ce qu'elle se croit que déjà à
l'intérieur même des partis politiques
et des groupes politiques il faut être
intransigeant et c zéro tolérance sur la
corruption des élus en fait les groupes
de pression les lobbys au parlement
européen non mais si vous achetez non
moi oui c'est pas la corruption et les
lobbies par la corruption et je viens
vous parler de présenter ses positions
et défendre ses intérêts ils font ils se
sentent à nous à nous arriver bien à
côté c'est la cohésion oui mais en ce
qui me concerne on m'a jamais proposé de
valises de billets donc je dois pas
accepter des valises de billets mais on
a vu il ya eu cette fameuse
caméra cachée vous savez qu'il ya piéger
quelques parlementaires en début de
mandat sur de la corruption en échange
de dépôt d'amendements quand on connaît
le finance le fonctionnement du
parlement européen on se demande
d'ailleurs comment on peut payer pour
déposer des mandats voilà mais
la réponse du parlement européen et des
groupes politiques a été immédiate et
les députés européens ont été exclus du
parlement européen donc c'est ce que
j'appelle 0 code zéro tolérance parce
que ce qui met la suspicion sur
l'ensemble de la classe politique c'est
d'eux qu'il n'y ait pas de sanction des
rares cas de corruption sont
corruption clientélisme etc sont
dévoilées et que ça n'a pas de
conséquence donc là dessus il faut être
intransigeant oui je crois tu vrai mais
moi ce qui me rend tout de même quelques
fois un peu étonné c'est c'est de voir
qu'on connaît si bien le montant de la
corruption parce que si on connaît le
montant de la production c'est qu'on en
connaît parfaitement les rouages et donc
si on en connaît rouages on peut prendre
des mesures pour essayer d'éviter ces
comme l'évasion fiscale ou lice a fait
tant de milliards si vous n'avez pas
l'évasion fiscale vers y ait moins
d'impôts mais alors pourquoi on prend
pas les mesures je crois qu'il ya eu un
problème de volonté politique c'est vrai
parlons un peu de politique politicienne
at elle qui vous concerne les élections
c'est le 25 mai comment elle se passe la
campagne
jean paul gauzès vous êtes vous n'êtes
pas sûr d'être élu important vous est
cité comme étant l'un des
députés les plus influents aller plus
est en 3d élections site vous un peu
aléatoire 1 c c'est le jeu de la
démocratie je suis en troisième position
dans une région nous avons au total 10
des poulies à dix députés et nous avons
quatre sortants donc on peut penser
compte tenu des résultats de du week-end
précédent que ça devrait les mais on
n'est jamais sûr françois scassa de vous
vous avez été carrément évincé de la
liste ps oui on peut dire ça comme ça
il n'y a pas de justice et non je sais
pas c'est sans doute aussi le mode de
fonctionnement le monde de constitution
des listes
on est en europe hebdo merci nous avons
celui resté avec nous sur les chaînes
parlementaires